we are in problem seven problem seven
and when we draw what they have drawn oh
they do a right triangle looks something
like the right triangle looks something
like this and then they do another
triangle that looks like an isosceles
triangle though we can't assume can't
assume anything in this life nothing
comes for free all right this is X this
is y u v w those are the angles and the
triangles above what is the average
arithmetic mean of u v w x and y so
what's the air so we're you have to just
add up the sum of the angles and then
divide by the number of angles so we
want to take u plus V plus W plus X plus
y and then divide by the number of
angles so there's one two three four
five angles so first question what is U
plus V plus W u plus V plus W well they
form the angles in a triangle so they're
gonna add up to 180 degrees and what's X
plus y well it's a 90 degree it's a
right triangle so and all three of these
angles have to add up to 180 right X
plus y plus this 90 have to add up to
180 so X plus y is going to be equal to
90 just subtract 90 from both sides so X
plus y is equal to 90 so if we take the
sum of the top 180 plus 90 that's 270
divided by five see 5 goes into 270 525
7 2015 4 so the average is 54 degrees
that's the arithmetic mean of all of
those angles and that is choice E next
problem
I certainly switched back to my bad luck
yellow all right problem eight like
they've drawn the problem eight okay
looks like a raid and if an arrow on one
side and say they say that this is
switch colors so they say that this is X
to the third this is x squared this is X
if X x squared an X to the third line a
number line in the order shown above
which of the following could be the
value of X so the first thing we know X
is gonna be as as well the first thing
we know that X is a positive number
how do I know that because if X was not
a positive number
well let me think about that right X has
to be a positive number because let me
put it this way if if X any negative
number any negative number let's say
it's negative one half if you square
negative one half if you square a
negative one half you get positive 1/4
so in any for any negative number the
square has is gonna be bigger than the
number itself so we know that this we
know that X is greater than zero that's
one thing we know what else do we know
we also know that X is going to be less
than one how do I know that because x
squared is less than X right and that
only applies for numbers less than one
right because 1/2 squared is equal to
1/4 and 1/4 is less than 1/2 so we also
know that X is less than one so we just
have to find a choice where X is greater
than zero and less than 1 and if we look
at the choices greater than 0 and less
than 1 there's only one choice that that
applies to and that's the 3/4 choice C
all right you might want to say 3 how
that's one and a half that's greater
than one the first two choices are
negative the last two choices are
greater than 1 or greater than or equal
to 1 so we know it's choice C
next problem and if you didn't want to
do an abstract wind if you have a lot of
time if you're really fast in the
problem you do know you can always try
out the numbers but that takes longer
I need your coordinate system right here
and this is my y-axis this is the x-axis
and then they draw a line that goes
through the origin a line that goes
through the origin something like that
and then they tell us they tell us that
this point right here at this point
right here is the point 1 comma 3 so
this is 1 this is 3 now what do they
want us to do with this and the figure
above line L passes through the origin
this is line L pass what is the value of
K over H oh and then they label another
point here they say this is H comma K
all right so what is the value of K
divided by H so the Y value over the x
value right the Y value over the x value
and I'm gonna tell you right now the
value of it is going to be the slope of
this line and how do we know that
because this is if you if you were to
subtract if you were to if you wanted to
figure out the slope from the origin
right if you wanted to figure out the
slope from the origin to this point what
would it be the origin of course is 0 0
right so it would be change in Y change
in Y is 0 minus K you wouldn't have to
do something SCT I just want to show you
that it would be the slope and then
change in X would be 0 minus H and that
of course is equal to minus K over minus
H the negatives cancel out and that
equals K - 8 K over H so they're
essentially just asking us what is the
slope of this line well that's easy
enough because they to give us another
point and so we can say well we could do
this rise over run so here what is the
change in Y change in Y is equal to 3
minus 0
I'm taking this as kind of the initial
point 3-0 change in X is 1-0
so change in Y over change in X is equal
to 3 and that's our slope and that's our
answer
the answer is a next problem problem 10
you're saying the absolute value of M
minus 3 is equal to 5 they're also
telling us that the absolute value of K
plus 7 is equal to 15 in the equations
above M is less than 0 and K is less
than 0 so it don't say M is less than 0
and K is less than 0 what is the value
of M minus K so M is less than 0 right
so there's there's two possibilities
here you could you know this first
equation if we didn't see that it could
mean two different things you could say
M minus 3 is equal to 5 or M minus 3 is
equal to negative 5 this one would solve
to M is equal to 8 and this one would
solve to M is equal to minus 2 well we
know M is not a because M is less than 0
right and to solve this I just added 3
to both sides so we know that M is minus
2 similarly let's take that second
equation that tells us that K plus 7 is
equal to 15 or
k plus 7 is equal to minus 15 subtract 7
from both sides of this you get K equals
8 subtract 7 from both side of this you
get K is equal to minus 22 and they tell
us that K is also less than 0 so we know
that this is K and they want us they
want us to know what M minus K is well M
is minus 2 and K is minus 22 so minus 2
minus minus 22 so that's the same thing
as minus 2 plus 22 and that is of course
20 and that is choice E
I will see you in the next video